good morning angels morning charlie I've
got a killer angel pose I wish you could
see right now the iconic trio of
ass-kicking ladies is returning but with
some new faces so get ready for the
excitement if there's a lot of laughter
there's a very intense action honestly
when I watched the action I was there he
shot it and I've been editing it
together and I still get like ooh like
what's gonna happen here's everything
you need to know before you go
[Music]
this kind of took this world that we've
all gotten familiar with and just
expanded it she kind of just hit
fast-forward and thought where would we
be
circa 2018 dating this is not the spy
agency from the 70s that your mom or
maybe dad aspire to be a part of clearly
we have a new set of angels and multiple
Bosley's in this new and improved
Charlie's Angels film but before we get
into the present let's take a stroll way
back down memory lane
I feel like Charlie's Angels at the
beginning of female empowerment on TV
you just hadn't seen women like kickin
butt uh-huh in any genre before and they
really stand for something in the
original season of Charlie's Angels we
had Jill Sabrina and Kelly these three
women were all police academy graduates
recruited by the Townsend agency the
series focused on their crime-fighting
adventures as private investigators the
dynamic trio always took direction from
the head of their private detective
agency Charles Townsend who always
remained unseen the series lasted for
five seasons on ABC amid lots of changes
in the cast John Bosley another employee
of the Townsend agency is the only one
who seems to know what Charlie looks
like David Doyle who portrayed Bosley on
the original series along with
Jacqueline Smith and John Forsyth were
the only actors to remain on the show
during its entire run did you know the
iconic Farrah Fawcett was only on the
first season her spot in the trio was
filled with a new character her sister
on the show this show remains a cult
classic in 70's culture icon and 2000
the Charlie's Angels film franchise
launch starring Cameron Diaz Lucy Liu
and Drew Barrymore the film franchise
remained true to the essence of the show
we got to see three beautiful strong
women kick ass to uncover truths and
save lives given you advances in
technology we witnessed higher stakes in
the plot accompanied by high-energy
stunts John Forsyth also reprised his
role as the iconic charlie we still
never saw his face
Angeles good morning charlie we did get
two new actors playing the comedic and
trusty assistant to Charlie Bosley Bill
Murray in the first Charlie's Angels of
the fire and Bernie Mac and Charlie's
Angels full throttle
I got cinema but I can't Holly wall
Charlie's Angels also launched an a
short-lived reboot of the series on ABC
in 2011 this time around in the 2019
version the Townsend agency has a whole
new set of our movie is a continuation
of the original Charlie's Angels
franchise only now the agency has gone
international so we are in Germany there
are many Bosley's and all across the
world Elizabeth Banks plays boss who is
also an ex angel as well story is about
these three women who come together to
ultimately fight injustice and help my
character Elena oh and let's not forget
the villains they're the ones who supply
endless drama in any story in the first
Charlie's Angels film the villains were
Anthony aka creepy Thin Man and rich
scientist Eric Knox in the second film
we had Madison Lee played by Demi Moore
and Oh sister did we get some good fight
scenes so it'll be interesting to see
how things unfold in this one this movie
is about the formation of the team and
it's really about how two current angels
bring along this new recruit in Alaina
hofland who's a science nerd basically
with no aspirations for taking down
international criminals but they all get
involved in this case and through this
they really form a bond a team they love
each other and love working together and
of course duh we can't forget about the
Angels Kristen and I
and I spent a lot of time just doing
random stuff just so that we had that we
found that bond and how we each find our
little thing and how we move so that
when they all fight together and we all
work together as a team it's super code
like a semi worked really well with each
other which was amazing let's introduce
you to the new ladies think about the
Angels is that they all bring something
different to the table so Elena who's a
scientist and can hack anything and has
this incredible skill set when it comes
to engineering and mechanics and
computers is very unlike Jane who's
really a weapons specialist who is
military trained and so she's very she
really understands sort of chain of
command how to run an operation and then
Sabinas the wild card of the bunch she's
got skills that you wouldn't even know
where they came from they came from
prison and they involve a lot of
hand-to-hand combat she loves her knives
she loves just being sort of brutal when
necessary she's like oh she's like our
blunt force not sure about you but I'm
pumped to see this news story and
Charlie's Angels franchise you know if
you kind of know how to broach something
with compassion and kind of like
intelligence I think it's it's not about
doing a bunch of push-ups and pulling a
gun on a bad guy it's like you know
outsmarting someone and doing it for a
good reason and that will genuinely be
what prevails in addition to the fresh
faces in the film we've also got some
a-list talent in action we have
incredible guys in the film as well no
Ascencio came in sam claflin is
incredible the movie of course sir
Patrick Stewart's like one of my
all-time favorites Djimon Honsou is
incredible in the film we put together
such a great cast and as as an actor
Zach
I just love being with all these guys so
now you know and now you can go see
Charlie's Angels in theaters November 15
[Music]